good evening it has happened again a
wrong way driver causes a crash
changing lives forever and tonight the
family of the two men that were killed
over the weekend are speaking out
wondering
what can be done to stop this brian yeah
71-year-old porfirio robledo gonzalez
and his 42 year old son
rodolfo were hit on u.s 95 right near
rancho this happened
at eight in the morning on saturday
christian casaros joins us live in the
newsroom with
the family's message christian that's
right well as you can imagine the pain
is unbearable for the robledo family
losing these two hard-working men that
just meant so much to them
he has no idea the pain he has caused
all due to a huge responsibility the
family of 71 year old porfirio roberto
gonzalez and his 42 year old son rodolfo
are trying to comprehend what happened
to them saturday morning
the other driver was drunk he was
driving he was speeding
the day had been hit head on and the
crash had
instantly killed him family members say
both men were hard workers and were on
their way to a side job
to help pay bills i think we're all in
shock that is the first word that comes
to mind because we still don't believe
this
rodolfo leaves behind four boys under
the age of ten
my life without the family had this
message to share
those of you who are drunk or dropped
you do not know the damage that you
caused
driving in the state there are innocent
people on the road
truly heartbreaking well a gofundme page
has been set up to help
with cost of both funerals and of course
to help the family now we posted a link
on our website eightnewsnow.com
christian casadas 8 news now